les malades déprimés que je rencontre en
consultation
entendre toute la journée ben prend donc
un peu sur toi fais un effort bouge-toi
ça ira mieux c'est aussi absurde de
demander à un déprimé de se bouger et de
prendre sur lui que de demander à un
hypertendu de baisser lui-même sa
tension artérielle la dépression c'est
par définition un état dans lequel la
volonté ne suffit pas et le fait de
prendre sur soi ne va pas guérir les
maladies si ça suffisait ce serait
formidable et ça s'appliquerait à
l'ensemble de la médecine lui c'est le
professeur Michel le joyeux chef de
service de psychiatrie et d'addictologie
à la PHP point brut il va s'attaquer aux
idées reçues sur la dépression
les symptômes de la dépression sont
difficiles à identifier
tout l'objet de la psychiatrie c'est de
faire la différence entre les moments de
tristesse normaux et la maladie des
précises regardez quand on est triste
quand on subit un événement désagréable
on est fâché prenez par exemple le
moment du confinement quand on a dû être
confiné on était triste mais qu'est-ce
qu'on avait envie on avait envie de
sortir le déprimé premier signe à une
perte d'envie ça c'est quelque chose qui
va faire de manière spécifique la
différence entre tristesse normale et
maladies dépressive le deuxième signe
c'est la perte de l'estime de soi quand
on est triste on en veut au monde entier
on se retrouve pas assez payé pas assez
mais pas assez reconnu le déprimé trouve
qu'il ne vaut rien et le troisième signe
c'est la perte d'énergie le
ralentissement dans le corps et le
ralentissement dans l'esprit j'insiste
beaucoup sur cette différence entre
attention normale et dépression nos
collègues neurologues ont diffusé les
signes de l'accident vasculaire
cérébrale maintenant tout le monde sait
aujourd'hui que quand on est paralysé
d'un membre il faut aller en urgence à
l'hôpital je voudrais que la même
information se fasse sur ces trois
signes pertes d'envie perte de l'estime
de soi perte d'énergie quand vous voyez
quelqu'un dans votre entourage
professionnel dans vos amis dans votre
famille dans cet état-là vous ne faites
pas de la morale vous considérez qu'il
ne va pas bien et qu'il peut et doit
être aidé
la dépression n'est pas une vraie
maladie et on est tous un peu dépressif
il y a une erreur en médecine il y a une
erreur dans la vie quotidienne c'est de
dire on est tous un peu déprimés quand
on voit l'actualité qu'elle soit
politique en fait tout ce qui nous
arrive on est tous déprimés la réalité
médicale la réalité de la psychiatrie
c'est qu'on peut tous avoir des moments
de tristesse des moments de
découragement des moments d'agacement
mais la dépression est une vraie maladie
avec des signes précis et des
traitements précis donc on ne peut pas
dire on est tous déprimés certains sont
malades de la dépression et d'autres pas
et la dépression est reconnue dans la
classification internationale des
maladies comme toutes les autres
maladies
les antidépresseurs sont dangereux et
rend dépendants il faut essayer de s'en
passer
[Musique]
si vous dites que vous prenez des
antidépresseurs dans une soirée tout le
monde va vous dire tu devrais tu devrais
pas tu devrais essayer le mien la
réalité sur les antidépresseurs c'est
exactement comme les antibiotiques ça ne
doit pas être automatique il s'agit pas
de prendre des antidépresseurs à chaque
fois qu'on est triste ça ne servirait
évidemment à rien il ne s'agit pas de
manière systématique de refuser les
antidépresseurs aux maladies dépressives
pour être précis il y a aujourd'hui un
protocole clair qui dit que l'idéal dans
le traitement des dépressions
caractérisées c'est l'association entre
un antidépresseur et une psychothérapie
pas l'un pas l'autre l'un et l'autre
il y a toujours un élément déclencheur à
la dépression quand on le trouve on va
mieux
quand j'ai appris la psychiatrie et
c'était malheureusement pas hier on
faisait la différence entre ce qu'on
appelait les dépressions réactionnelles
où on trouve un événement et les
dépressions qu'on appelait endogène qui
est censé venir de l'intérieur d'un
terrain biologique aujourd'hui dans les
classifications internationales que ce
soit celle de l'Organisation mondiale de
la santé ou de la mécan 58 association
on ne fait plus cette différence parce
qu'on sait que quelquefois il y a des
causes quelquefois il n'y en a pas et ce
n'est pas en remontant aux causes qu'on
traite les déprimés mais en repérant
leurs difficultés et on les aidant
d'abord ce qui veut pas dire qu'après on
cherchera pas les causes dans les CI et
maintenant
[Musique]
guérit bien des dépressions quand on est
déprimé
on est exposé à ce qu'on appelle un faux
amis le faux amis c'est le verre
d'alcool pourquoi parce que le verre
d'alcool quand on le boit va donner un
petit coup de forêt chacun son aperçoit
quand on boit un ou deux verres d'alcool
dans un dîner on est un peu plus gai on
raconte pas les mêmes histoires à la fin
du dîner qu'au début du dîner mais
pourquoi c'est un faux amis parce que
tout prouvé toutes les études prouvent
que le fait de consommer de l'alcool
quand on est déprimé à grave la
symptomatologie dépressive augmente le
risque suicidaire fait que la dépression
est plus difficile à traiter donc faux
amis absolus il semble faire du bien
mais en fait il fait du mal et il
aggrave
les dépressives sont en réalité des gens
désocialisés
la dépression isole quand on se met à ne
plus avoir de désir plus avoir d'estime
de soi on va se couper de son travail
parce qu'on a du mal à travailler de sa
famille de ses amis c'est bien pour ça
qu'il va falloir repérer cet état et le
traiter mais c'est les liens ne sont
jamais aussi simples toutes les
dépressions ne vont pas conduire par
exemple à une désocialisation complète
mais il y a dans la dépression un impact
social qu'on va réduire d'autant plus
que on peut ne pas la nier ne pas la
daigner demander un avis médical et
rapidement traiter le problème
la dépression ne touche que les adultes
la dépression est plus fréquente à
partir de 18 ou 20 ans et chez les
adultes on peut malgré tout voir des
dépressions chez les enfants chez les
adolescents elle va s'exprimer de
manière différente par exemple pas une
cassure de la prise de poids par des
troubles du comportement la dépression
est très fréquente 10% de la population
sur toute la vie la bonne nouvelle c'est
que la dépression peut et doit se
traiter dépression et déprime ce n'est
pas la même chose
sur tous les mots de la psychiatrie il y
a une sorte de récupération dans le
langage général vous savez tous nos
diagnostics de personnalité par exemple
sont des insultes il y a comme
psychiatrie on voit ça si on voudrait
d'hystérique de paranoïaques de
narcissique c'est pas un diagnostic
c'est une insulte pour la dépression le
terme de dépression a été repris dans la
dans le langage commun sous le terme de
déprime la déprime n'a aucune définition
médicale s'il fallait trouver une sorte
d'équivalent pour dire que la déprime
c'est la tristesse c'est l'émotion qu'on
ressent de manière passagère et qui ne
doit pas être traitée mais la réalité
c'est que la notion de déprime ne doit
pas faire oublier que chez certains qui
se conservent comme atteinte des primes
ils sont en fait atteints d'une vraie
maladie dépressive qui doit être
reconnue et traité donc concrètement
n'utilisons pas ce mot déprime utilisons
éventuellement le terme de tristesse qui
est beaucoup plus juste pour définir une
émotion et celui de maladies dégressives
la dépression peut être
des douleurs ou d'autres maladies quand
j'étais jeune on parlait de dépression
masquée on disait il y a des gens qui
ont pas de dépression mais ils ont mal
quelque part ça doit bien cacher une
dépression la réalité aujourd'hui telle
qu'elle ressort de nos études comme
celle qu'on conduit dans le service ici
montre qu'un certain nombre d'états
dépressifs avec ce qu'on a dit la perte
d'envie la perte d'estime de soi et la
fatigue s'accompagne de douleur donc
dans ce cas là la douleur est un peu
déclenchée par la dépression et quand on
traite la dépression on fait disparaître
la douleur mais il n'y a pas et c'est
bien prouvé maintenant de dépression
masquée donc si on a mal aux oreilles le
nez bouché mal à la tête n'allons pas
imaginer que c'est une dépression si on
n'a pas les signes de la dépression on
ne guérit jamais complètement d'une
dépression
[Musique]
les malades psychiatriques dont je
m'occupe au quotidien
subissent une double peine un c'est pas
des vrais malades c'est pas comme les
malades de cardiologie comme les
cancéreux qui vont mobiliser de
l'émotion de l'empathie deuxième idée
fausse on les guérit pas c'est vrai pour
l'alcoolisme et c'est vrai pour la
dépression la réalité est complètement
inverse un déprimé bien traité qui a
bénéficié d'une psychothérapie qui
surtout en amont a été reconnu comme en
état de dépression peut être traité et
totalement guéri donc ces maladies
aujourd'hui se guérissent ce qui ne se
guérit pas c'est le déni qu'on peut
avoir vis-à-vis de ces maladies la non
reconnaissance la méfiance ou le mépris
qu'on peut avoir soit vis-à-vis des
malades soit ceux qui les soignent si
vous voulez plus de contenu sur la
dépression et la santé mentale n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner à notre page YouTube
en attendant de vous retrouver sur notre
page nous vous disons à bientôt